ah il y a quelqu'un dans
une non il n'p pas leurs voisins ils
guettent les
hirondelour ces trois bénévoles se sont
donnés rendez-vous au pont du routtoir à
Guille en cours pour compter les n
encore occupé depuis 2009 les irondelles
forment une espèce intégralement
protégée l'année dernière la Ligue pour
la Protection des Oiseaux lanc une
enquête nationale de recensement
Philippe et son équipe 40 n à Guy encour
et ses alentours cette année après de
mois de migration depuis l'Afrique
subsaharienne ses ambassadrices du
printemps sont arrivés en masse début
mai alguille en cours on rencontre deux
sortes d'irondelles les irondelles
rustique celle que l'on trouve dans les
granges à l'intérieur des bâtiments et
puis les hondelles des fenêtres celles
qu'on voit en façade dans les coins de
fenêtres avant
avaient choisi les vieux B les bâtiments
de leur époque mais maintenant elles
savent très bien s'accommoder de du du
des immeubles récents puisque là on a
des immeubles qui ont 40 ans après la
phase de contrôle Philippe entre en
ligne les données en 20 ans 41 % des
hirondelles de fenêtres ont disparu les
raisons la destruction des nids et
surtout le manque de nourriture dans les
villes il y a plus d'insectes à la
campagne bah le type de le type
d'agriculture qui est faite à l'heure
actuelle de culture en qu' y a plus
d'insecte non plus donc
ces oiseau il me de fa le code de
l'environnement prévoit jusqu'à 15000 €
d'amende si vous délogz uneond petit
mieux vaut donc participer à l'enquête
et recenser les nid il n'y a qu'à lever
les
yeux